réponse en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis new york avec caleb maupin
correspondant berthet aux etats unis
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir caleb bonsoir le policier décédé
au capitole une mort naturelle on vient
de le dire selon l'autopsié est-ce que
cela change quelque chose à alain tac du
capitole je ne le pense pas les
conséquences politiques de cet événement
du capitole le 6 janvier restent les
mêmes les images que le public américain
a vu à la télévision de ce capital
attaqué par des manifestants
le fait qu'une femme est été tué par
balles le fait qu'il y ait eu des
confrontations dans le bâtiment du
vandalisme
pour moi le sentiment du public
américain les conséquences de cet
événement ne changeront pas suite à ce
nouveau rapport de topsy calmement par
vous restez avec nous puisque on va
aborder un autre thème un aux etats-unis
puisque donald trump ne s'avouent pas
vaincus l'ex président pourrait bien se
présenter à la prochaine présidentielle
américaine en 2024 j'y pense très
sérieusement c'est ce qu'il a déclaré un
pendant une interview sur la chaîne fox
news
c'est la première fois qu'il a quitté la
maison blanche pour laisser la place à
son successeur joe biden en attendant le
45e président des états unis dans le
viseur de la justice de new york elle le
soupçonne de fraude fiscale et bancaire
également de pression sur les
responsables an des élections dans
l'état de géorgie écoutez je dis cela je
m'y intéresse très sérieusement plus que
sérieusement d'un point de vue légal
je ne veux vraiment pas en parler pour
le moment c'est un peu trop tôt à
laquelle m on vous retrouve donald trump
y annonce qu'il envisage sérieusement de
se représenter en 2024 mais je cite que
d'un point de vue légal
c'est trop tôt que veut-il dire il fait
allusion à ces affaires justement
judiciaire
lorsque donald trump parle de l'aspect
les gaz de son annonce il parle à auzat
de financement des campagnes avant qu'il
ait créé un comité de campagne avant
d'avoir organisé tout le système de de
réception des dons de campagne il serait
en violation du droit américain
donc il doit commencer par organiser son
système organisé la collecte de fonds de
campagne
avant cela il ne peut pas déclarer sa
candidature
l'argent est très importante pour les
élections américaines en règle générale
c'est le candidat qui a récolté le plus
de fonds qui gagne il y à des
contributions directement pour l'autre
candidat mais également pour les comités
d'action politique qui sont beaucoup
moins transparent je pense que donald
trump n'annonce pas sa candidature car
il ne peut pas encore commencer les
levées de fonds donald trump qui a même
insinué qu'il y penser comment cette
annonce en tout cas de j'y pense a été
accueilli aussi bien par les
républicains que par les américains en
général se retrouve chez le public 1
c'est un néoconservatisme développé lors
de la dernière guerre froide avec le
président reagan et ensuite à l'heure de
la présidence bush et bien cette fille
ce jour elle m'est devenu éculés
américain ne veut plus en entendre
parler cette idée que les états-unis
sont le meilleur pays qu'il suffit de
les ménager et si on n'est pas content
le fonctionnent plus aujourd'hui car il
ya beaucoup de colère envers le
gouvernement et donald trump a modernisé
le conservatisme afin d'y incorporer la
frustration envers le gouvernement les
théories du complot qui sont le plus en
plus populaire à droite donc cette
théorie qui sont marche bien et pour moi
donald trump est le meilleur espoir des
républicains merci qu'elle avait un mot
pas un correspondant aux vertes et aux
etats unis d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france ce soir